So now when we have introduced indexes, let's
talk about the size of these index tables,
since this is important to be aware of
when you build datastore applications. Using the developer console,
you can see the index sizes under the
datastore dashboard page. Here, we display the dashboard for
a very simple application. And as you can
see, the entities themselves do take up 6.75 kilobytes.
However, the built-in indexes for those entities, they
take up 57.12 kilobytes. This is actually a
common scenario. Indexes very often take up more
space than the storage required just to store
the entities. The built-in indexes are the indexes
that are generated for each of the individual
properties, as we talked about for the conference
city property. There's also something called composite indexes,
but we'll talk about those shortly. As you can see, if you let data store
maintain an index for each individual property, it can take up a lot of space.
Therefore, it's important to think about which
properties you need to query on. So you
only generate indexes for those. Let's look at
how you can control that in your code.